When I do retreats, it's best if people
know the fundamentals. So, here's how I
define the fundamentals. Starting with
split time, same direction where you're
comfortable with the forward and the
backward weave uh and windmill and you
can turn between them. So, you can be
pretty you can freely turn around in
split time, same direction with the poi
and you know different patterns doing
that. Same with the same time moves. You
can do shoulder reels and hip reels. And
you can turn around and do some tricks
fairly comfortably with opposites. You
can pass it over your head, behind your
back. Uh shift alternate which one's in
front all inwards and outwards.
And you can you're starting to dance and
play freely while you're in regular
opposites. And same with split time
opposites. You can pass them around your
body. You can turn from inwards to
outwards. It's a funnier one to go over
the head. So, we usually go around the
body. Um, you can go over your head, but
uh it's a funny feeling. Uh, and that
you can use stalls or speed changes to
go between split time interaction and
opposites,
uh, etc.
So you don't have to be a master at
every single bit of that, but you want
to know most of that uh and be on well
on the way to being comfortable with all
of that. That means we'll be able to go
deeper into rhythm and expression and
learning flowers and more advanced
stuff. So that's what I define as the
fundamentals.